good afternoon I'm Joel Young I lead the
Machine inference infrastructure team
and Linkedin down here is my partner
beau long he leads the machine learning
algorithms team together we're leading a
complete rethinking of how machine
learning is done at LinkedIn today we'll
walk through what happened to start us
on this journey we'll give an overview
of our products and how AI contributes
the opportunities were facing and how
we're scaling our technology and our
people to meet these opportunities here
are some of our key products all of
these have one thing in common you can
think of them as providing a view into
the economic graph consider your
linkedin connections your connections
connections and so on this explicitly
defines a graph a little snapshot into
the economic graph but it's not the full
graph it's not exactly right there's
people that you work with on a day to
day basis that you haven't connected to
and there's also people certainly ones
in this room that if you were introduced
to if you got to meet it's probably part
of why you're here today it would bring
value to you would bring value to them
you can think of the people you may know
product is addressing this problem
basically finding the missing edges in
the graph we have feed product finding
the information that you need right now
to bring value things like articles new
articles updates from your connections
and even job opportunities when you are
looking for a new job
time for the next play our job
recommendations product helps you find
the right job to move to sometimes
you'll find that that job there's a
skills gap it might be missing something
our learning product provides
recommended courses from our large
library in LinkedIn learning to help
fill in the gap by the way there's
courses in there for almost everything
I'm going to talk about today including
deep learning tensor
etc on our sales navigator platform we
help sales folks identify the
influencers at companies the decision
makers can help find a path to them to
bring value likewise on the recruiter
product we help companies find exactly
the right talent people like you to
drive their mission so it's pretty clear
that all of these products have AI and
machine learning at their core how do we
go about designing the AI and machine
learning to address these products so
the key is to start at the product goals
itself work with the product managers
work with our customers or members look
at what are the needs what are the
budget how much time work and drive from
that product metrics that we can measure
success against then we work with the
data science analytics to refine the
product metrics to relevance metrics
concrete measurable signals things that
will become the labels when we move on
to the machine learning stage we then
join the labels with features drawn from
that economic graph and move into the
training state the modeling and training
stage we'll talk a lot more about this
stage later on once we've trained a
model we ship it to production when we
bring it to production we don't just
throw it out there and start serving we
use an extensive a be testing system to
scientifically evaluate whether or not
the new model is meeting our business
goals evaluate against product metrics
relevance metrics performance metrics
etc and make informed decisions as to
whether to continue to ramp or to back
off and this is a continuous cycle it's
going continuously constant product
refinement so
pretty clear that machine learning is
driving all of this it's also hidden
places in our stack you have things like
anti-abuse spam detection fraudulent
account detection and also things even
in the build system you might be
deploying a product and the deploy fails
historically when the deploy fails it
goes back to the dev who is pushing the
service and they try again might work
this time why do they try again well
there could be one of the causes that is
is their mistake the other causes could
be a random hardware malfunction out
there somewhere on the grid or it could
be an act a bug and non determinism in
the deployment stack if we can apply a
model to this look at the situation when
the failure happens and direct the fault
to the team that's most likely to be
able to fix it we can shave off a
significant amount of time and help
build trust in the developers into the
build system ai is eating the software
world many of our products have evolved
over the past decade and they're built
from substantial amounts of carefully
engineered code in fact we have over a
hundred search verticals and
recommendation services providing
relevance machine learning into our
products each of these services was
custom-built by different teams in the
past we've led a few efforts to try and
standardize the machine learning
components in the stack unfortunately
these have often worked they bring value
they help bring in a new technology but
what they don't end up doing is minimize
reducing the complexity they don't
replace things they just add another
part what I call second system syndrome
also we have many different modeling
technologies in use there's simple
logistic regression tree ensembles deep
learning additive ensembles of all of
three of the above our workflows are
built with things like pig dolly
five spark scalding cascading etc tons
and tons of different technologies okay
also all of these services are mission
critical to the company whatever we do
as we try and advance the state of the
art we need to reduce the risk of sight
issues and when they do happen we need
to make them easier to troubleshoot also
there's some secular trends that are
happening in the world machine learning
is becoming democratized it used to be
the case that it was an ivory tower
skill you needed a master's degree a PhD
and machine learning maybe physics but
now we're seeing people come out of boot
camps coming out of online courses
people taking the Coursera courses
people taking pretty high quality
courses even in their undergrads so I
linked in what we're finding is almost
every engineering team product teams UI
teams all of them have people with
meaningful practical AI skills
remember again AI is eating a software
the engineers they want to solve their
problems now they have the skills to do
it they don't want to be blocked by the
machine learning gods but there's too
much friction in the stacks
too many stacks too many technologies
too much manual work to gather the
features design and train the models
deploy them into production and to keep
them running so also another of the
secular trends is the rate of
advancement in machine learning
approaches and even more in the tooling
to build them is accelerating almost
every day if you followed the right news
sources you see big companies and labs
announcing new tooling things like
tensorflow
cafe to TLC onyx spark ml Lib
the list every day the list cooler is
longer so we could considered spend a
fair amount of time thinking about hey
is the right solution that we go all-in
on one of these stacks
maybe tensorflow maybe PI torch
but we can't know which one of them is
going to win the shakeout Wars that
almost certainly are going to come and
most likely what's going to happen is
they're each of these stacks are going
to carve out a portion of the space each
one are going to be bringing values to
different classes of models different
styles of problems and we don't want to
bind in if you look at the clean
architecture book you oughta talks about
guidelines one of the things is delay
your decision-making and in any case we
already have a few texts that we know we
have to build support for so as we
design as we build our future for
machine learning it needs to be
extensible by us and not on the core
infrastructure and machine learning
teams but also by our end users even the
UI teams they come up with a new tech
that exactly solves their problem they
need to be able to bind it into what
we're building rather than having to
build their own thing then we're gonna
have to clean up the tech debt later on
right you've probably heard of the
fundamental rule of engineering fast
good cheap pick two historically we've
picked fast and cheap good and cheap
this brought very quick value to the
particular products but it's also part
of why we always end up with a second
synth system syndrome we don't actually
reduce complexity this time Bo and I are
able to go in with the other two choices
fast and good and by fast what we're
really focusing on is fast iteration
speed for the modelers fast
experimentation cycle we aren't
forgetting cheap but now it's cheap to
serve not cheap to build so what is our
particular goal our concrete target goal
is to more than double modular
efficiency model or productivity one of
the things we found is that there's a
direct connection between the modular
inter iteration speed as long as that
iteration is coupled with early feedback
directly drives improved model improved
product metrics
we're doing this focusing on the model
creation stages deployment stages and
then maintenance or running continuous
monitoring of the models running in
production we're divided the problem
into a set of layers we have
experimentation in authoring exploring
the data science exploring the economic
graph trying modeling approaches driving
down into the training layer vast
clusters GPUs distributed training
systems moving down into packaging up
the artifacts the artifacts can be
surprisingly complicated and large
moving them into the right production
environments and then running in
production running in production as well
and in the training are the two places
where the fast and cheap comes in all
right it's reading through all this are
two pillars we have what we call the
feature marketplace this is where we
look at better technologies for
generating features things like sliding
window feature aggregation count
services also feature a feature pub/sub
system where you can as a development
team modeling team you might come up
with a pretty cool feature maybe you
have a new deep embedding that can
capture a member profile and you're
getting a lot of leverage
you've heard of this idea of transfer
learning you want to share it with
another team historically that's been
extremely complicated what we're doing
is we're separating this is the data for
the feature this is the semantics so
features have a name as a modeler all
you need to do is know the name of the
feature the providers of the data
provide anchors in each of the execution
environments offline I'll get it from
this Avro file this auric file this
dolly view online it'll come from this
key value store or this REST API down in
search it'll come from the query or
it'll come from the inverted index or
the forward index on the other side
we have the assurance the health
assurance constant monitoring constant
checking to make sure that the systems
staying healthy that when we're
designing a model all the way down in
the authoring stage that the features
are available online giving warning
maybe it's okay that they're not
available yet but you want to know the
part of your deployment process is going
to be needing to get the features into
production
checking for offline online consistency
etcetera I'll talk a little bit more
about this later okay so how are we
organizing this some of you may have
heard of McChrystal's team of teams
model so historically organizations are
very hierarchical you have managers have
managers reporting those managers you
have teams we're not doing this project
in this sense what we have instead is
for each of those layers each of those
pillars we have a lead usually it's an
engineer a tech lead and the engineers
working on that come from across the
organization some of them are up in
product engineering some of our ma are
in our tools chain some of them are
working in the modeling in the relevance
org some of them are in infrastructure
also we have a leadership team of which
Bo and I are part of the leadership team
isn't directive we're not telling people
go do this go to this what we're setting
is direction for the project vision and
we're looking for places where there's
friction building up where people aren't
learnt knowing what they need to know
about the different parts sometimes
there's too much collaboration the way
things are set up teams are having to
talk too much it's slowing down progress
then we'll help dig in and find a better
API a better boundary between the
projects other places there's not enough
communication so actually going back
since we are talking about machine
learning one of the ways you can think
about this is that the leadership team
we're really just a stochastic gradient
descent optimizer we're trying to find a
more global Optima for the project
hopefully not to stochastic though okay
it's also distributed across the world
we have participation active
participation from our teams in
Bangalore from Europe and from our
multiple teams in the US so what exactly
do we mean when we talk about a model if
there's one thing you can take away from
from this is a model for our purposes
it's just a directed acyclic graph it's
just a deck you have a set of input
features you have transformations on
these features and that's it some of the
transformations can be really simple
things like convert a categorical
feature into a one hot it can be linear
algebra operations interaction features
maybe do a cross product or an inner
product between two vectors it can also
be very rich transformations like
compute use tensor flow to compute a
deep embedding some of these
transformations in the dag are also
trainable there's unknowns in them wild
cards that need to be figured out so
this is a notional dag for one of our
job recommendation models we'll talk
about this a lot more later on when we
discuss the training but at a high level
there's a set of input features we have
raw member profile text we have raw job
text from the raw member text maybe we
need to compute a deep embedding project
it down and to say a hundred dimensional
real vector maybe we also have a set of
standardized features standardized job
title seniority geo locations etc
they've been processing through
streaming pipelines from these we might
computed a deep interaction model
projection maybe a probability of click
through using job embedding member
embedding and we might take the output
of that all our other features and learn
a random forest with something like X
boost we have some other models that go
into the mix we'll talk about more later
and maybe we combine them into a with a
linear combination so how does the
engineer actually go about building a
model like this for our hard core
modelers the way they often like to work
is we just provide intellij bindings for
dsls they work on the models just like
other code and then they use the build
and deploy tooling to run the trainers
and the exploration on spark and Hadoop
for everyone else we provide Jupiter
based exploration and authoring
environment in addition to a great
interactive experience we find that by
using the Jupiter hub it really
motivates engineers to not pull personal
member information down onto their
development boxes on this slide you can
see a view into a Jupiter notebook with
a notional two-dimensional title
embeddings actual title embeddings are
far far higher dimensionality but it's
hard to project them so then building
the model now we talked about having a
dag the model is just a dag but when we
represent it what we've found is that
the models get quite interesting and
complex and having a graphical drag the
boxes around it seems cool people go ooh
and pointy-haired bosses like me
sometimes get excited about them but
they don't speed up development they
don't speed up learning they maybe speed
up the first half-hour and remove the
fear factor what we need is a lot more
control a lot more insight into what's
happening and for this we have a
declarative DSL that we've built
in-house called quasar short for quick
ass scoring and ranking so you can our
previous one was called loser back four
years ago which was short for logistic
score but no more negative names so here
you can see a little section of the
model we're can
a cosine angle between two of the
embeddings a member embedding and a job
embeddings we're also applying a tree
model to compute scores the scores might
be a probability of apply a probability
of click-through if you can get the
signal maybe it's even a probability of
what's called in the ads world a
conversion the probability that the
person actually gets the job and we can
figure that out it just takes a month or
two for people to update their profiles
you know we know that they applied we
know they clicked and eventually we'll
know if they got the job so also the dsl
provides what you might call as first
order operations it can actually work on
lists of entities can work as a rancor
and not just a score so you can see at
the bottom we're taking a list of all
the jobs all the documents ordered by
the score we can do top KS we can do
filters we can do diversity z' split
lissa part bring this together all sorts
of operations on the list themselves
okay all right so of course people want
to be able to explore their data using
the jupiter notebook so you get that for
free can tie into matplotlib Python
tools that everyone knows and many
people know and love and also we provide
hooks so you can drive your your
larger-scale work you don't want to do
heavy lifting within the notebook itself
but you know the data is far too big to
even run on a single box even if we drew
a few terabytes of RAM in but drive it
over to spark notebook I mean to spark
running on the big clusters you can see
a little notional comparison coming out
of the results for two versions of the
model accuracy and area under the curve
so Bo is going to walk us through how we
train the models thanks Jill so like you
mentioned right the goal production
machine learning is to help our engineer
to do model kini productively so let's
take a look how do tree no mado
so to chill machine your mother will
either key key components to key
components why it features which are
data we prepare for the model Trini
normally we refer each variable as a
feature another key component there is a
algorithm so which take the features and
the input optimized objective function
and a neuron model so feature a [ __ ]
together we can learn a model let's take
a look at the feature first so why in
the age of big data so even for a single
model we could have meanings or features
at the linking we seen a lot of
different models for different products
so overall feature space is huge as you
all know right and the in the practice
feature engineering is major efforts for
the model Trini one time the professor
enjoyed a Stanford said apply the
machine learning basically just a
feature engineer so I'll link in so to
make feature engineer more productive we
build this framework all the feature
marketplace so for our engineer to share
discover or explore the features easily
so with this feature marketplace and the
nearest can contribute their own feature
to the future marketplace and the big
through this feature marketplace so
people can easily get all the
information about the features like how
a feature was generated and which models
which features and the history of the
feature distributions we also provide on
a lot of other powerful tools right like
how you do feature selection how do
validation and the monitoring of those
features
so with fatima microplace engineers can
find that the features for their model
shinny
very productively yeah I also want to
mention one Challenger is specifically
for a feature mark place so how we make
sure that engineer actually gets all
these
ask for right I'm talking about the
avila island consistency you know when
we do a lot of who are my experiments
together good a feature works so very
well but there's no guarantee you
actually can get a stable future online
because there's always a lot of steps
could be generated description between
Allah and Allah so we build a linking we
build a frame or platform which cannot
generate a feature of Allah Allen based
on the common libraries and the same
configures so make sure our online
consistency also the height of the
feature television details from engine
years so the model is only needed to
specify the feature name then they can
easily get a fish for the Avalanche
healing and also get to the future when
they do the online model scoring also
the frame was look for the other
powerful tools like a feature joining so
make sure that you do the feature
journey very efficient so in summary
with this feature marketplace our
engineer can easily identify qu the
features for your model Trini with Allah
and Allah consistency so I will have the
feature now let's look at the algorithm
our link Lee we have three major type of
the algorithm first wise deep learning
which is a popular algorithm based on
multi-layer neural networks the link we
use a tensorflow to Trina and deep
learning
we used Dibner need for both feature
generation and the prediction follow
physical relation we generated our
content bindings for models for example
which are also order and bending for
user profile which can be used for like
Java recommendation we also use for the
prediction dippin Ernie
especially for some challenging tasks
like a language understanding and the
imaging understanding a second hard
workers who use a linking is a trees
basically ensembles more trees
selectively we use the trees
both centuries algorithm implemented in
open-source packaging extra boost so
posting trees it's very good at captured
nonlinear interaction within data so
we'll use putting trees for both for
fiscal regime and also prediction and
the third have algorithm we develop our
own a gross package based on the concept
of a general linear mixed model which is
powerful model for recommendation
applications assuming all right general
linear model it's a popular model for
the response prediction for example
logistical regression for battery
response prediction right linear
regression for the numeric response
prediction and the Poisson regression
for the country response prediction
there are all the special types of the
general linear model when we use a
linear general linear model for the
recommendation we also want to capture
specific information for space user or
specific item for example we need a job
recommendation you also want to capture
specific information for other user
normally we do this by incorporating key
know user ID features or automatic
feature into the model so you cross
other features with a user ID when we do
this oh actually between the general in
your mixture model so in huge scene is
very simple here picture one of our
tweets we have a global model which you
use all the data and all the features
but on a type of Gulu model you use the
data only for specific a user to choose
small producer model on a topic local
model
similarly you also to provide more model
just for that atom like a job yeah
by doing this you have a deeper percent
dilution so the idea is simple but the
computation for the grocer is very
challenging
think about we have 500 mini members are
linking even each member model only have
one cell in the future that's a huge
lumber yeah that's why we develop our
own angles of package yeah
and true to these general leagues
mixture model yeah we also open source
this extra package name is full-time
male please feel free to give it a try
more than not we also generalize a
general linear mixed model to the longer
model so now we are also supported we
can show a non linear model for example
we can use the tree model for the
caliber model but I'm not happy tree you
can chew another pro user model for
example just based on no juice
regression yeah so it's very flexible
powerful for a recommendation so I don't
have the features have the algorithms we
also build into Trini and you called a
photon connected connect all the
chaining process together so this engine
gonna hold a frame like I mentioned
before to prepare our features making
sure our online feature is consistent we
also called a different type of
algorithm do though all the feature
transformers based on a dag and the
finish is the final model Trini and well
how I will create up to do the online
model serving of course it's gonna be a
repeating process you keep getting the
feedback and then you improve your model
with another training cycle now let's
take a look at a specific example this
example for lingering job recommendation
first take a look at the feature where I
recommended Java to our members sohow
member features and the Java features
for Java features or how to type one is
member profile text feature which is
just a feature based on raw Rotax
information which has a lot of evasion
very rich information but it's quite own
noise yeah
another one is a member standard feature
which surely color based on structure
data extract the information based on
standard format is much cleaner but it's
has not seen information for the job or
her job site I have a similar situation
so let's look at how we generate a
feature now for the Rotex
feature like I mentioned has a rich
information for the noise that's why we
can use it even learning to extract
Ambani's which remove the noise but I
gathered more can't wrap the right
features so we have the different
learning for a member and also for the
job
together we'll also have interaction
features also based on neural network
interaction now we have the feature
based on the deep learning we also have
standardized the features how a feature
already now we do the fun final model
training like I mentioned before we use
a general linear and mixed model yeah so
first we pick half of the trees now
forest its ensemble cheese and sour
croco model which you will take all the
data all the features ok the global
model can do the prediction but on the
top of the global model also treating a
per user model and the project model you
can see per user model will only use the
data for other user based on Java
features on the other side we also only
use the or the other feature for special
job for the portal model and then the
pretty gather will be in the final model
which cannot be recommended the job to
our users
after Oh hapless model and the Joel talk
about how we gonna deploy and how we use
is model
thanks Bo so if you think about the
model that Bo just talked about if think
about a naively or brute force
what we have is over five hundred
million members over ten million jobs in
our inventory if we tried to do an all
pair solving
we'd have at least five gazillion member
job pairs that we'd have to solve sorry
I can't say that number out loud so but
fortunately we don't have to do it that
way there's structure to the model
so there's the global component this is
that deep interaction model combined
with the XG boost the tree model we take
that those two parts and we take the
quasar dag package them up and we push
them as an artifact down to all of our
search or search or nodes then if you
think about the per member components
really these are just a vector of
numbers they're the coefficients for a
logistic regression we can just take
those and put them in an online key
value store index by say the member ID
we can take the per job coefficients
again just a set of numbers treat them
as features and just write them into the
sharded forward index it's deployed to
the searchers now if we think about this
when a model like this is actually going
to be used we're not doing it for all
the members we're doing it for the
member that is on the site so we don't
have 500 million members to deal with we
have one so make that makes the problem
five hundred million times easier but
even ten million jobs is still a lot of
work how do we do it in practice so
remember comes to the site they navigate
to the jobs page and when they do that a
rest call goes down to our job
recommendations mid-tier the job of the
mid-tier is to integrate everything we
know about the situation it reaches out
to our standardized data stores pulls
the things like what's the members
current job what's their industry where
are they geo looks it reaches out to the
model store and pulls that members
coefficients by the way which
coefficients should it pull well it has
already checked against the a/b test
platform you know which model is this
particular member seeing then by the way
it also uses the frame system there may
be other features you know which
features did it get from the
standardized one it's the ones that the
model down in the searchers are gonna
need bundles it up sends it in the query
down to the search cluster the broker
takes it apart shards it out to a whole
bunch of searchers then on the searcher
it takes the per member portion coming
in from the query
it takes the features from the forward
index takes the global model puts it all
together runs the quasar inference
engine the inference engine supports
lazy modes it supports columnar modes
batching so that it can keep vector
pipelines hot etc then the results come
back out and we can do this fast enough
that we give a real-time experience to
our members so we've got they're running
in production how do we keep it healthy
well one of the things we've found this
is obvious but it's not obvious when
you're stuck in the in the loop the more
work you do to keep your models healthy
early in the lifecycle the easier it is
to keep them healthy when they're
running in production so in the health
assurance thing we we add a lot of
verification and validation steps like
even down in the authoring environment
you've crafted this model it uses a set
of frame features are those features
available online are they updated fast
enough in the online environment to be
giving you the robustness that you need
is there checking constantly is their
offline versions of the features
consistent with the online version of
the features trying to use the same
calculations on both sides trying to
avoid some of the problems with the
lambda architecture that we see
basically constant monitoring constant
checking one of the common patterns that
you see machine learn models they're
trained on a set of features the
performance of that model is going to
naturally start degrading as the world
drifts from the world that was in place
at the time that you trained
historically what's detected is oh we
start to see business metric impacts
must be time to retrain the model the
natural inclination is to delay that as
long as possible because it's been
difficult you have to make sure the data
pipelines work again maybe it's been a
month since you've retrained so the next
step is to go look at your data and then
make a guess all right if I retrain and
deploy weekly maybe with a something
like a cron job it works good but then
the reality is is that
weekly sometimes it's too slow sometimes
it's too fast so we're either throwing
away product lift or we're throwing away
compute with the monitoring system we
can be tracking this degradation and
when it reaches a threshold we can
automatically trigger a retrain and
deploy so another part is continuous
online anomaly detection in a sense not
in the sense in reality anomaly
detection is just another kind of
machine learning model so we're
monitoring our model deployment system
with a model trained in our model
deployment system part of our alerting
system is to actually ask the people
receiving the alert hey was this a true
anomaly was it an anomaly but it's
actually a new trend in the world it's
not a flaw in the system it's just new
information that we need to integrate
into our modeling processes was it a
false positive or huh don't know yet
right so talked a lot about what we're
doing to scale up the technology make it
easy but that's not enough people are
coming in more and more with machine
learning skills but not everybody also
we have our own stack so people learn
stuff with Weka or tensorflow or this
toolkit or that toolkit they've got to
come in and learn our own so we've set
up this thing called AI Academy we have
a blog post on it you can read more one
of the interesting classes is we have a
course for managers so they're not going
to be doing the machine learning
themselves they'll be leading people who
are and what kind of problems are
actually solvable
what are they reasonably likely to get
good results from and what are still
what we call AI hard problems also how
to evaluate success concepts like
precision and recall and F score is an
area under the curve and how to create
well well-structured
a B tests and understand significance
and things like that also in
understanding people in the audience do
machine learning you know that
it's a fundamental Rd problem it's very
hard to say in one week we're going to
have a model that's gonna bring a half a
percent lift probably not gonna happen
but it might could take two months
depending on how hard the problem is so
who's heard of the idea of a success
trap few people so what a success trap
is is it's when a company when a
business when a team when an individual
gets stuck in since it's machine
learning talk in a local Optima they've
learned something of the world
they've had success but they've over
learned them over fit this piece of
information and they miss opportunities
a classic one is Kodak with digital
cameras missing the transition even
though they are the ones who invented
digital cameras so there's a particular
success trap that I call the support
trap that I've seen happen many times
with new new infrastructure components
you adopt your customers customers come
in too quickly each customer that joins
has a finite support cost if you bring
in more customers than your team can
support the team is now frozen out you
can't continue doing strategic
development you only have two choices
one is you can evict customers that's
kind of a painful thing to do or you can
try and get more resources you can find
more engineers to bring them in but you
if you waited too long now you're a bad
bet right people have started losing
face your customers aren't happy you're
not quite serving them it can be hard
and even if you do get the head count it
can be slow to bring them up to speed
it's much better to avoid this so what
we're doing in the productive ml project
is we're not doing a whole scale
adoption instead we're going component
by component even sub components and the
layers and pillars in each one teams
adopt and each adoption makes the next
part of the adoption easier
something maybe they want to use the
quasar modeling language and the
inference engine maybe they want to use
the feature marketplace system maybe
they want to use the monitoring stuff we
also look at each component and we rate
it pre alpha alpha beta general
availability and we limited option
depending on where it is in the curve
pre alpha alpha will have very specific
partners that have agreed to accept some
of the risk that's involved the benefit
of course is when it pans out they're
way ahead of the curve on the adoption
cycle so in conclusion we've presented
our approach to complete overhaul on the
machine learning stack at LinkedIn you
can find more at our engineering blog
and we're open to questions you can put
questions up on the slide oh I haven't
seen anybody using it so far but you're
welcome to i'll start the app up and or
you can just ask and we'll repeat the
question back so there's still no
questions so anyone have any questions
go ahead
yep yep that's a great question so the
question was when one of our modeling
teams comes up with a new feature they
want to publish it for sharing how do we
sense provision the infrastructure who's
responsible for running that
infrastructure and to be honest we're
working through the details on that
feature sharing is a lot like getting
leverage with your code sharing you get
it's awesome you're bringing efficiency
and you're binding yourself because now
you can't change your API anymore
you have to deprecate and provide end of
lifes and all that but right now our
target is the provider of that
infrastructure I mean the provider of
the model owns their infrastructure now
the key value stores have sre teams that
run the key value stores the Kafka and
Samsa streaming teams have a series that
run the various clusters but just as
they were responsible for the
infrastructure that they used before
they published it part of their decision
on the publishing is to continue the
responsibility now if a feature gets a
lot of leverage it's going to move to
one of a couple teams the
standardization team that produces
features that are generally usable for
business metrics and for machine
learning and relevance or to a common
features team that's more focused on
relevance driving features that are
generally leverageable thank you there's
a question over here
yep yep so the question is first for a
small team of the modelers it can be a
big challenge to move from that to
getting a full scale model in production
today did I get that about right okay so
this is a big part of what we're trying
to do and this is where the
democratization comes in the by using
the components in our architecture
starting with the Jupiter notebook tied
in with the quasar DSL support the frame
support tying over to the photon connect
the bow talked about basically a team if
they if they use this infrastructure
they're greatly increasing the
probability that what they build will be
deployable using the rest of the
infrastructure they're still we're not
gonna block anybody if somebody wants to
go out try something new do their own
thing they can but they're gonna be on
their own they're not going to get
support from the relevant site
reliability engineers etc did that any
other questions
yep so so the question is what are we
doing with hyper parameter tuning yep do
you want to talk about hello hello can
you turn on the mic so that's very good
question right actor I should mention
that so like we said when I was so huge
a feature space basically means that we
have the huger primed her space so yqp
older the comm hole in the color auto
CUNY so can automatically turn the
parameters even further come complicated
model like how you put a long year model
tree and the linear deep learning
together which is a ratio based on the
gaussian precise so the other house have
every tuning a lot yeah
any other questions
yep
so the question is we have the course
for the managers have we had any issues
with the managers say it again oh it
managers being part of the problem
instead of the solution so truth in
advertising right now the machine
learning infrastructure that we have is
more in at this point in our productive
mlpro ml it's more like the old way
where it's awkward and difficult right
now in our classes there's every person
who goes to the machine learning process
the AI Academy is partnered with
somebody in the relevance team for an
apprenticeship so it's we're only taking
product in teams that have partner
relevance team machine learning teams
and they're working through together so
there's a fair chance that we will see
issues like you're talking about and one
of the things it's actually pretty
likely because engineering managers that
LinkedIn are engineers they actually
build things and that means that some of
the managers might they might take both
classes they might take the how to do it
and how to manage it classes hopefully
with the two they'll avoid being part of
the problem but we welcome stress right
it's only by people trying things that
were on the edge the edge of our
envelope that we learn in advance so
there's going to be challenges and
they're going to be good ones I think
other questions going once going twice
sessions closed
[Applause]